okay really good yeah you can just feel
it just burning yeah okay Carly can you
describe to me the vibe back here today
guys we're backstage at the Victoria's
Secret Fashion Show and there's a lot of
pink there's a lot of beautiful angels
running around it's it's exciting
there's adrenaline I you know we're a
couple hours out before the show starts
and we're all getting ready and it's
just kind of the chaos of backstage but
this is a very special backstage well
yeah people are calling this the biggest
v/s show ever like how would you
describe the show it's exactly that it's
the biggest v/s show ever and we're in
Shanghai and there are I mean I think
over 3,000 people who are going to be in
the audience watching there's a really
big beautiful set that's been built it's
gonna be quite a production and I know
that I know that also I think they said
they're estimating many millions of
people who will be watching so with so
many people being here to watch and so
many millions watching do you ever still
get jitters and nerves before you get
out there of course I'm getting nervous
now just talking about this who would
you rather go sightseeing in Shanghai
with Harry Styles or Miguel I mean I
think I'd rather go no offense to those
guys but I'd rather go sightseeing and
Shanghai with all my girls with all all
the angels who are gonna be walking the
show yeah now there been so many amazing
models walking Victoria's Secret runway
who is your favorite most iconic angel
of all time that is a loaded question
there are so many women that have graced
this runway that I really admire and
respect I mean I think back to you know
obviously Gisele come on she's the
ultimate angel the woman across the way
from me right here Candice Swanepoel is
one of the most graceful beautiful just
elegant women that you'll ever meet and
she wears those angels she wears those
wings proudly
but also there's such legacy to this
runway and you know thinking back to the
original shows definitely see more back
in the day and what the show maybe even
one of the first shows and also Adriana
and Alessandra have walked so many shows
I think Adriana told me the other day
that she walked this is this is our 19th
show 1999 was it's alright 1999 that's
amazing
many many many shows rocked now a lot of
people see the Victoria's Secret models
as absolute perfection but what would
you say is your like least angelic
quality well like nobody's perfect that
is get that straight even all of these
beautiful angels are you know we're all
we're all human and I think one thing
for me is like you know I feel really
lucky to be a part of this show and to
be on that runway with these girls and
more than anything else you want to feel
your best and whatever it is that that
can help you get to that point is what
you want to do leading leading up to the
show so I live a really active life I I
like to run I just ran the New York City
Marathon and you know I think you want
to do whatever you can to feel your best
but nobody's perfect and I think it
doesn't matter if you're an angel or and
ready to walk the show or not you just
want to feel the best you can and your
skin phenomenal thank you so much best
of luck tonight gonna be fantastic